I'm sorry. I'm just getting
this. Breaking news.
♪
Now, back
to a "Tub Watch 2016" update.
Updates now. The total count is
now 17 dead from cuteness.
Let's check in with the puppy's
progress and see how he's doing
with that bath live
from the scene.
(audience sighing)
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Mm.
Yeah!
HARDWICK:
Mm.
Not sure what breed that is.
It looks like something
a Muppet baby coughs up
when he chokes on cotton candy,
but it is (bleep) adorable.
Comedians, this puppy is
permed and dangerous.
I would like you to give me
an eyewitness description
(duck quacking)
Flula.
Oh, it looks like a deer
has pooped on a cloud.
-Yes. It does, yeah.
-(laughter)
Points. Yeah, these look...
these are little poops.
Little poops.
Tiny deer poo-poos.
Aw, that is adorable.
Aren't you guys feeling better
already about the world?
-(cheering) -Knowing
that this stuff's out there.
Aw...